à travers des animations des
démonstrations également des essais le
public a pu découvrir les innovations et
avancées technologiques de demain
notamment le smart grid développé par vd
comme et à deux types de stockage un
stockage court terme c'est à dire par
exemple tout simplement en rechargeant
les batteries d'un véhicule électrique
tout comme vous rechargez les batteries
de votre smartphone tous les jours c'est
un moyen de stocker de l'énergie c'est
un stockage court terme à côté on
travaille sur un stockage long terme
entier par exemple fabriquer de l'eau en
hydrogène alors pourquoi fabriquer de
l'eau en hydrogène vous nous direz vous
simplement aujourd'hui dans les maisons
on peut chauffer des ballons d'eau
chaude et c'est un moyen ce qu'est
l'énergie donc pourquoi pas partir de ce
moment-là transformé de l'eau en
hydrogène pour ensuite venir alimenter
une flotte de vélos électriques qui
fonctionnent à l'hydrogène et dimanche
dernier on pouvait découvrir aussi ce
vélo à hydrogène une bicyclette qui
possède une autonomie de 100 km à
attirer les curieux je pense qu'il ya la
mer
d'autant que l'autonomie si elle est
confirmée à hauteur de 100 km dépasse
tout ce qui existe aujourd'hui quoi
je pense qu'il ya un marché
effectivement au travers du vélib avant
que le vélib électriques arrivent
sur le marché maniable il freine il
accélère comme un vélo électrique non
tout se jouera c'est en fait sur
l'autonomie et le temps de recharge
c'est le plus du vélo il faudra
patienter jusqu'en 2017 avant que le
vélo à hydrogène ne soient
commercialisés en attendant l'événement
a rassemblé environ un millier de
personnes et a été un véritable succès